it was a normal day at the nebulous
office the man who worked the front desk
sat with a large teeth-bearing smile as
five people entered the lobby and
approached him
after confirming their company's
identity in discern the man escorted the
group up a set of stairs and through a
labyrinth of hallways they passed tables
desks and offices occupied by nebulous
employees their heads all positioned in
a similar way staring forward at a
screen or piece of paper necks stiff and
tilted at about a 45 degree angle
in an effort to be liked the man from
the front lobby asked the incoming
guests questions about their travels and
familiarity with the area as the group
answered the man from the front lobby
still holding his smile tightly in place
proceeded to ask the same series of
questions he asked every person or group
in the scenario
eventually they reached a large
conference room at the end of a long
hallway inside there said other men and
women all sitting with rigid necks and
straight postures to match their faces
talking discreetly without any apparent
body motions or gestures
the man from the front lobby knocked in
the room slightly ajar door and all the
men and women in the room turned their
heads in synchronization the man from
the front lobby introduced the group of
guests to the group in the room and then
in an almost ethereal manner quickly and
discreetly disappeared back down the
hallway the original curl of his smile
now inverted into a sort of droop
[Music]
with big fervent smiles showing various
amounts of teeth the nebulous group in
the room stood up and welcomed in the in
discern group with nearly the same exact
motion speed and firmness they all shook
hands executing a methodical degree of
force in an effort to show both
confidence and compassion
and achieve the optimal first impression
in an effort to be liked one of the men
made a joke while introducing himself
it wasn't entirely clear what the
punchline was but in an effort to be
liked all the others in the room laughed
profusely
a woman a part of the indiscerned group
being introduced made a joke back
no one in the room found this joke to be
particularly funny either but the
extreme laughter picked back up until in
an almost instant it cut out completely
still smiling tightly as if dead lifting
their cheeks each man and woman sat down
at the large ovular table in the room
the meeting commenced and everyone said
something even if they had nothing to
say
when each person spoke they spoke
carefully and methodically according to
their particular role in rank analyzing
the consensus and direction of the
conversation and sharing their
statements and opinions accordingly just
enough to appear uniquely capable of
confident independent thinking while not
so much so to risk appearing more
capable or a threat to their superiors
just before the meeting ended one of the
nebulous men offered for the in discern
group to join them all for dinner
in an effort to be liked and maintain
good relations in sync the group agreed
enthusiastically although they were all
very tired and eager to return to their
hotel
[Music]
at dinner the whole group shared
witticisms and opinions about pop
culture current events and entertainment
as well as other non-specific work and
personal life anecdotes modified and
embellished to ensure favorable and
interesting appearances
all of which opinions and anecdotes
included everyone seem to share and
agree with
a young waitress served the group and in
an effort to be liked was careful to
maintain a bright bubbly personality
engaging and reciprocating in the
group's humor and banter knowing that
the men and women's attire indicated the
prospect of a large tip
throughout the dinner the group loudly
laughed and huffed while the banter
continued as if they were a tv sitcom
laugh track for the show of the
restaurant
none of the men and women were having a
good time no one was particularly fond
of anyone else both between and within
each group each person's effort to be
liked preoccupying their own head
sufficiently enough to keep everyone
from being able to really know and like
anyone else
in each moment each person was trading
the individuality of self for the
preservation of self
and in doing so
no one knew anyone
in this world it only mattered that the
self fit
not that the self was real
[Music]
by the end of the dinner everyone was
extremely tired intensely desiring to
return to their hotel or home
following dinner everyone stayed for
several more drinks
after the outing finally concluded each
man and woman returned to their home or
hotel room they slouched watching
different forms of media on their tv
phone or laptop nervously anticipating
the next day in which they would again
continue to work to preserve the self so
that they could remain the winners they
dreamt to be
this video was sponsored by blinkist
no matter what cog in what machine we
might be our personal time is sacred and
making the most of it is of course
incredibly important whether it's on a
commute at the end of the day in between
activities or during breaks in your
schedule the book summary app blinkist
can help you turn your spare personal
moments into more meaningful and
enriching opportunities to learn more
about what you like what you care about
and hopefully who you really are
blinkist works by taking over 5000 of
the best non-fiction books in 27
different categories
pulling out the key takeaways of each
book and forming them into around
15-minute text and audio summaries that
can be read and listened to even while
offline
additionally blinkist also has summaries
of popular podcasts and a wide selection
of audio books available directly within
the app making it easy to learn from a
huge selection of voices in a
comprehensive range of ways
if you're interested in learning about
identity or the implications of social
conditions on the sense of self blinkus
has some great titles a good combination
to read together being humanity works by
alexandra levitt manufacturing consent
by edward herrmann and noam chomsky and
the ego trick by julian bajini which can
help inspire you to question key aspects
related to your sense of self for
yourself from illusions created by it
and lead to a better understanding of
who you are and aren't the first 100
people to use the link in the
description will receive one free week
of unlimited access as well as twenty
five percent off a full membership the
free seven day trial can be canceled at
any time within the trial period
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you next
video
[Music]
you